what's going on everybody and welcome to
a video series that might have me more
excited than any other series before
most of because I don't know what I'm
doing here I know some of the things
that are possible but I don't know
everything and it's gonna be a lot of
stuff that I have to learn and hopefully
we can learn together so what I've got
here is the open BC I think what I've
got is the starter kit I could be
mistaken we'll break it down in a second
but basically the idea is so you can
read
EEG data from your head I've think
neural link just without needing this
machine to embed electrodes into your
brain it just sits right on top
non-invasive and you can read brainwaves
I believe also in here we've got things
for ECG and EMG like reading muscular
movements and stuff like that mostly I'm
interested in the EEG stuff but honestly
I'm just super psyched about checking
out all of this technology so let's dive
in so inside the box we've got two for
some electrodes I think these are just
for use with conductive paste though
then we get the actual conductive paste
some electrode wiring they also sent me
their headband kit if you're looking for
a cheaper entry into EEG data this is
probably your best bet sticker next we
get the battery pack the sight on board
and the Daisy board the battery is for
headset power though we're gonna wind up
using something else the sight on board
is eight channels and then the Daisy
board gives us the other eight channels
for sixteen total so now for the main
act of the show we have the ultra cortex
mark 4 headset on assemble but 3d
printed - pretty good perfection here
each octagon is a spot for an electrode
and the unit basically just rests on
your head
headset electrodes jumper wires for them
inserts for the headset electrodes and
then the last of my electrodes
oh and also some ear clips and that's it
now we're ready to actually assemble the
headset so the official guides simple
enough they've got a video and a text
write up lots of photos it's pretty
useful the kid overall is pretty
expensive you can go down from 16
channels to eight to save some money or
just go with the headband kit that I
referenced before for 200 there's also
like toys on the market with EEG like
you know to control cars you can convert
those maybe for 50 bucks you can even
try to source parts on your own and
build everything from scratch
I estimated I could do it somewhere
between 10 and 20 dollars per electrode
circuit and maybe even go lower but it's
just the quality was gonna be an issue
plus the whole I really don't know what
I'm too weakened part so the only issue
is with this battery as you can see here
this is if you have a standalone battery
it can kind of go in real nice and clean
there but the battery doesn't come with
the headset and I'm not really sure why
made for shipping reasons so they give
you instead of battery pack and this is
it
it's just taped to the top that's not
acceptable so so open bc i does link to
a battery from Adafruit but it's sold
out so luckily you can buy these little
lipo's like all over the place I even
have a few lying around for small drones
so which brings me to my next problem
and here you see two identical plugs one
is the battery pack that they sent me
and one is my lipo battery notice
anything catastrophic how about now I've
no electronics expert but I think rule
number one is don't reverse polarity so
I don't know if there's some stand where
standard somewhere for these plugs but
if there is someone messed up we need to
flip the lipo plug like the lipo battery
plug because these plugs can only go in
one way you know so people don't reverse
polarity to do this you just have to
lift up on some small tabs usually
people use like a screwdriver but I
actually just stuff a small thing in
like an Allen wrench where the wire goes
and I'll do the trick to pull it out
long story short always double-check the
polarities before you connect things
this could have ended in tears even
though the adafruit battery whistled
I did look at the pictures and it looks
like the plug was indeed opposite from
mine really weird I've got multiple
brands of these batteries and another
brand charger all of which are the
opposite of this headsets board and the
Adafruit battery but anyway once you got
everything together you can use this
little plug here and it's just a
bluetooth dongle they've got Mac Linux
and Windows support for their GUI that
you can just download once you've got
that go ahead and open the GUI you pick
various settings like which board you're
going to use how many channels and then
make sure that you can actually make a
connection to the headset so obviously
make sure the headset is you know turned
on once I sign go ahead and put on the
headset and clip on the ear clips you
might find the headset to be slightly
uncomfortable you just need to it like
adjust the electrodes in and out so if
you go too far in it might hurt or lift
up other electrodes and then too far out
you won't get any signal from the ones
that are too far out if all goes well
though you should see something like
this alright now that we simply could
not get any more cool what's next so
first of all this GUI is really awesome
as a programmer I look at this and I am
in total on env but I don't know we
can't really do anything from here
because one I can't really eat GData I
don't know what I'm really looking at
but to the hope is to do a
brain-computer interface at least to the
extent where I want to do control so
something like controlling something in
a video game for example is the first
thing I want to try so to do that we we
can only take one or two approaches and
that would be either some sort of
rule-based approach which is going to
require me to have some sort of Industry
knowledge which I don't owe or to a deep
learning approach which won't require
anything of me really except for coding
some deep learning stuff so that's the
first step I want to take now to take
that step I have to decide one how do we
get that data to what data do we get so
from quick research I'm just gonna bring
up a couple of things here just for
vague understanding for everybody if you
just google like brain wave chart you'll
find stuff like these charts okay so
this explains what each of like the five
major brainwaves are and what they kind
of map to I suppose so like Delta waves
these are like point 1 to 4 Hertz and if
you don't hurt PSA's you can dare I say
it's interchangeable with frame rate so
FPS and when I show you our code there's
going to be things that say FPS mostly
because we've copied and pasted the code
that because to measure the Hertz or the
sampling rate it's the same code you
would use to measure FPS it's not the
same and we'll talk about some of the
various issues hopefully soon but
anyways so delta waves this is like like
we're not going to control anything with
delta waves theta waves um I don't think
we're gonna control anything there
either so I think you could probably you
can tell if someone is like sleeping
based on theta and delta waves or and if
they're dreaming or not or something
like that then with alpha waves we could
tell I think and again feel free to
correct me I am NOT an expert this is
just me learning over time and what I
think where I'm at at the time so alpha
waves you could tell if someone is
relaxed what kind of state they're in
blah blah blah
beta waves this is your normal waking
state so information about that and then
gamma waves motor functions higher
mental functions okay so just from
reading that my very quick understanding
is that we really need gamma and beta
waves most likely somewhere in this
range is what's gonna be most useful to
an algorithm like if we're thinking go
left go right it's my expectation that
we would need information on this level
and the way this works is that the Hertz
this is like a sampling rate so if you
took this information and you had like
the raw data so let's assume gamma waves
this is the raw data so let's say this
was I don't know 60 Hertz you could
sample it to 30 Hertz so you could take
a 60 Hertz stream and sample it to 30
but you'd probably don't want to do it
let's say you can went 60 to 12 Hertz
this is what you got then he took 12
Hertz and you and well you wouldn't want
to go 7.5 but but basically each of
these is like a
less granular sampling of that raw data
that is whatever the baseline is so we
have a couple of issues here one is what
it what is the raw sampling rate that we
can get from the headset because we need
something pretty significant if we're
gonna get gamma waves like you probably
would want hundreds multiples to get
gamma waves so that's our first question
and then how to resample I'm pretty sure
we can use Syfy for resampling
information but anyways that's the
question
and now how do we get the data actually
just in Python so to do that it was
actually super simple you just go over
to learn down here software and
basically there's kind of two major
packages one is like Python or it's open
sea open BCI - Python or PI open BCI for
newbies like me and as I was reading
through here I just kind of got
eventually to this point where boom
print the raw data that's exactly what
we want right so so you have to install
things where is it yeah the pitman so
numpy pi cereal --bowl ah and then you
can pip install the PI open BCI but then
all it takes is this code right here so
let me show you guys a quick example of
that so fine take this copy pasta also I
need to stop that data stream I'm just
gonna close out of that so it's not
interfering with our new connection that
we want to make and over get to save
that and let me run that it'll say PI 3
7 read from dot pi oh we have a couple
issues here so first of all it can
automatically find the connection you
also could go into your device manager
to figure out exactly which comport
you're using but it can automatically
find it also Daisy is true so if you had
a different board you would import
something different here but I have this
site on board and I've got the Daisy so
that Daisy's that extra eight channels
so I may go ahead and save that in
you run that one more time hopefully
that works cool looks like it's gonna
come in and let me make this big screen
boom there's our data beautiful I
couldn't believe how simple that was
so thank you to the people at open BCI
that was really easy so so what you see
here is just a bunch of arrays and each
element in the array is a separate
channel so a separate channel is a
separate electrode on the head so this
is channel 1 2 3 4 5 and so on all the
way to 16 so pretty cool the only thing
that you can even see here is it appears
that this is not a steady stream of data
this is a burst of data which is very
problematic I don't know what's causing
that if is it just the print like if I
wasn't printing would it still be
bursting I really don't know so that may
or may not be an issue moving forward
but anyways it's currently happening so
I'm gonna go ahead and break that and
then what we need to know is even though
it is bursting can we find out what our
frame rate is so that's the next thing
and I'm just gonna copy and paste this
code and explain a couple of things just
because I think probably a lot of people
are just kind of following along for the
interest of what's going on here so I am
going to copy and come over here pasta
and let me just explain a couple of
things here for the FPS counter we are
using a deck if you don't know what a
deck is it's just a container that you
can say hey I want this container to be
50 and as I add new elements beyond the
50th element the new element gets added
at the end the oldest element gets
popped out really simple but deck is not
very fast so instead it with the help of
Daniel he wrote a kind of a numpy
version of a deck so basically it's this
and then these two lines here it just
mimics what deck does it just does that
way faster so so in this case it's a
sequence of 30,000 I'm gonna decrease
that just for now I don't actually I
think 30,000 was still quite fast I
don't think it actually made a
difference but anyway
I'm trying to think here so sequence
we're just populating that and again
it's sequence is going to have in this
case a hundred samples of the that
16-channel
array that you just saw in the console
output nothing more to explain other
than this that's commented out basically
I saved a couple of files because just
trying to iterate over the code and like
do some like R&D type stuff I needed I
wanted to just have a way to mimic the
headset without actually needing the
headset on because every time you break
the connection sometimes it can be hard
to reconnect stuff like that I'm sure
there's a nice way to like cleanly close
but like I said I'm honestly like going
through this lot almost live it's not
totally new so like some of this stuff
I'm just gonna write for you guys before
I hop on a video but this has been
learning as I go
so anyway did I say that I can't
remember yeah so this will give us our
frame right now so as you can see
there's a couple of things going on here
I'm just gonna highlight to pause this
number here appears to be the legit
framerate but actually it's usually more
like 105 like sometimes on the initial
connection and things are kind of slow
and then it and then it finally gets
more stable so oops let me yeah if I
catch it at the right time there we go
so as you can see most of them are
rating 106 105 I believe that's the real
sampling rate so you would say the raw
sampling I think is 105 Hertz but then
towards the end we get these much larger
numbers I've seen it be as high as 2,000
I don't know if that's because of the
bursting or what I'm gonna try to dig a
little deeper figure out what's going on
maybe ask the people at BC open BC I see
if we can figure out like what why is
that happening because that's gonna make
resampling challenging but still very
very possible you just have to resample
based on the index of time I think it's
totally possible to do it I just need to
know for sure that that's what's going
on so anyway it's about 105 Hertz now
this is a problem for a couple of
reasons one is since we're only getting
105 Hertz
going to our brainwaves here we're gonna
have a really hard time sampling to 30
Hertz like it we can do it it's gonna be
a stretch but it's not gonna be very
it's gonna be like totally accurate so
the only option we could just keep it
raw like and I think that's what I would
do for like a gamma wave I would just
keep the signal raw and then for the
beta waves I think you could take it and
say you know you can take 105 and
downsample to like 20 Hertz that's
probably fine and then everything else
from there but like I said I'm pretty
sure gamma and beta is going to give us
the information that we need you know
for control like if we're thinking left
thinking right I think we're gonna need
somewhere in these range okay so yeah if
I forgot to say it too I pretty sure I
can use sy PI for the actual resampling
but it really is going to depend on if
this is seamless or not I think it's
inverse ting so the next thing is I just
want to show an example because as you
saw with the GUI you know that the
Fourier transform that's nice because it
contains all over the Hertz like it
contains the 10 20 30 and it went all
the way up to 60 which has me curious
how are they getting 60 Hertz because I
don't think you could accurately
resample 105 to 60 Hertz so that's the
other thing I'd like to ask is how are
they doing that is it because they're
probably not using Python they're
probably using a much lower level
programming language and it might be the
case that in this case we don't want to
use Python we want to use you know C++
or something like that so for the the
actual raw data and then once we convert
it to a Fourier transform or convert it
to the you know gamma and so on
you know reefs and planes then throw it
into Python so who knows okay so now to
visualize what this data looks like over
a much longer time frame as well as in
the raw form and why we kind of sample
at different rates I'm going to just use
the following code so this code just
reads from a file that way I don't have
to have the headset on all the time
and this is sort of mimics what it would
do if it was reading from the headset at
let's say 105 frames per second or 105
Hertz so
cool so what we're gonna do is I'm
trying to think if there's anything here
I really need to explain it's just gonna
iterate over and then sleep for that
timeframe
unfortunately matplotlib can't plot at
105 frames per second anyways but I just
want to visualize the data and then
we're just breaking after the first
first one anyways but we can say here
like how many seconds do we want to
slice let's start with one second and
then we're going to just do channel
eight
so this channel eight in theory like
swim Python since we index from like
zero one word really channel eight would
be like Channel nine on the headset but
not that it matters at this stage so
anyways and then colon comma this just
means basically like the sequence of
data that we're working with this here
this is an array of arrays and those
arrays are those channel samples that
you saw in the console before so when we
say colon comma 8 we're saying we want
the eighth index of all of the arrays in
whatever array were indexing or we're
referencing rather and that would be new
data and new data is just a slice of
data ok so basically we're just graphing
channel 8 so if I run this we should see
yeah here so here's one second so you
can see there's like these big
fluctuations here but then it's kind of
hard to see but if we just kind of went
through the mid there's even like a
little bit of fluctuation going on there
so like if we go and let's say we graph
5 seconds you can see it even a little
more clearly here we solve all those
little fluctuations but in general
there's also a more macro fluctuation
going on here right that might not be
perfect but if you were to you know draw
like a moving average or truly resample
the data you would have something like
what my mouse is doing right it would
just be in this middle region so not
only do we have like these like really
granular waves we've got a little more
macro of a wave going on this this much
larger motion that's happening then if
we go even further out let's say like 20
seconds again there's there it's getting
a little messy and this is why we
to sample down but even as we go out
like if we go based up like kind of up
here I guess you can kind of see okay
there is some sort of like downward
trend it looks like right here right but
again if we were to continue to zoom in
though we'd see those familiar high
granular you know bumps basically
whatever you want to call those where
it's just these like zigzags and that's
as granular as the data gets so now if
we let's say we did 180 so what would
that be three minutes so this is three
minutes of that brainwave data Channel
eight now you can see there's even some
some even grander thing is going on like
we thought it was going down but
actually on the grand scale over three
minutes is actually kind of going up so
this is kind of why like we have like
very very macro and micro and why we
might want to sample in between because
as you've seen there's all cut there's
all kinds of different things so inside
this gigantic wave we've got these
smaller waves doing things so there's
there's just a lot of information
you know enclosed here so that's kind of
why we want a sample at different rates
one just to better understand what's
actually going on but to because at
least science tells us that the more
more granular of the granularity I
suppose or the sampling rate can inform
you on different things so this much
larger graph I don't exactly know which
one it is but I would say this is
probably one of our you know maybe a
delta wave or a theta wave right well
this information is very grand
information you know if someone was
really educated they probably could tell
if you were sleeping or not you know or
dreaming in your sleep and so on so
anyway cool so that's just some basic
intro to you know open BCI getting this
information in Python now to continue
I've got to learn about you know
resampling this data can we fix the
continuous nature of the data
what kind of neural network am I even
gonna try to use and so on lots of
things to look forward to so definitely
stay tuned with that I have the best job
and it is thanks to Channel members
and my new channel members are vegan
software cam Thiebaud peffer le jáchym
Rama Sri Conte / alum Singha Sens Jose
cow Paz you Katya var and Ramesh
Raghavan
thank you guys very much for your
support and of course all of you channel
members
I really really appreciate the support
you guys are amazing and I think that's
it if you got questions comments
suggestions Corrections all that stuff
feel free to leave them below honestly
I'm really learning all kinds of new
stuff here so yeah
so feel free to chime in if you've got
anything you want to say okay
so I will see you guys in the next video